الجغرافيا هي السبب الرئيسي اللي رسم
العقليه الروسيه ورسم العقليه الامريكيه
امريكا بلد حاربت كثيرا قبل استقلالها
وبعد استقلالها هي امه لا تضع السلاح ابدا
منذ عام
1776 منذ استقلالها وامريكا تقريبا في
حاله حرب مستمر وفي تقديرات مختلفه لعدد
الحروب والغزوات العسكريه الهائله اللي
قامت بها الولايات المتحده بعض المؤرخين
ولا حاطط لحضراتكم رابط ما اقول في هذه
النقطه وفي كل ما سبق وفي كل ما سيتلو في
مصادر الحلقه ومراجعها بيقدر ان الولايات
المتحده اشتبكت من سنه 1776 يعني منذ
استقلالها وحتى الف الفين وسبعطعشر في 188
عمليه عسكريه اما صغيره او حرب كبيره يعني
دائما هي في حاله صراع
لكن حروب الولايات المتحده هي حروب الدوله
المطمئنه حروب كلها في النهايه او الهدف
الاساسي فيها الدفاع عن مصالحها وليس
وجودها مش حروب وجوديه يعني حتى الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ايه اللي خلى الولايات
المتحده تدخل بشكل مباشر في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه هو هجوم اليابان على
ميناء
طبعا ده يستبعد عمل من اعمال العدوان
ومبرر للولايات المتحده ان تدخل الحرب لكن
هذه العمليه ما كان من شانها ابدا ان تهدد
مصير الولايات المتحده ولو وجودها على عكس
الروس حروبهم حروب وجوديه هم يدافعون عما
يعتقد انه اما ان اكون او لا اكون خذوا
نفس المثال الحرب العالميه الثانيه الروس
ما كانوا راغبين في دخول الحرب او الاتحاد
السوفيتي ما كان راغبا في الانضمام الى
الحرب لكن اللي دافعه للحرب هو غزو هتلر
في عمليه بربروسا سنه 1941 وبالتالي وجد
نفسه انه مضطر ان يحارب الالمان وبالتالي
الانضمام او التحالف مع الغرب
الولايات المتحده عندها الدافع الاساسي
وليس الوحيد للحرب هو ان تصبح دوله عظمى
تعالوا نشوف كده اتنين من منظري الحرب
البارده بيشرحوا الاستراتيجيه الكبرى
للولايات المتحده ومتى يجب ان تحارب
الاتنين دول
هم جورج كنان الدبلوماسي الشهير اللي كان
احد اهم منظري الحرب البارده والاحد اهم
مهندس العلاقات الامريكيه السوفيتيه ثم
الروسيه من وقت المبكر جدا والثاني هو
ولتر ليبمن وده ايضا كان كاتب يعني نشط
سياسي واحد اهم منظري الحرب البارده كما
قلت لحضراتكم
الاثنين في سياقين مختلفين عرفوا بعد
نهايه الحرب العالميه انه الاستراتيجيه
الكبرى الجراند استراتيجي للولايات
المتحده لكي تصبح دوله عظمى عليها ان تقوم
بقطع الطريق على صعود اي دوله اخرى في
العالم وتحديدا في اوروبا واسيا من ان
تمتلك موارد اقتصاديه تكون اكثر من موارد
الولايات المتحده ايه الموارد الاقتصاديه
ديت كل الموارد القدره على الانتاج
الصناعي والتكنولوجيا والسلاح
واجمالا قدرات صناعيه كبيره ليه تمنعها
لانه من وجهه نظرهم اذا امتلكت اي دوله في
العالم قدرات صناعيه اكثر من قدرات
الولايات المتحده سوف تصبح مصدر للتهديد
للولايات المتحده وهو ما لا يجب ان تسمح
به امريكا ابدا على امريكا ان تتاكد انه
انها سوف تحارب وسوف تحشد وتقطع الطريق
على اي دوله قامحه في ان تصبح في وضع يمكن
ان يهدد الوضع الامبراطوري للولايات
المتحده ما يعني ان امريكا حاربت الاتحاد
السوفيتي
وتحارب الان او تسعى للحرب مع الصين ومع
موسكو او مع روسيا ليس بالضروره لان هذه
الدول دول معاديه ولكن لانها يمكن ان تمثل
خطرا على الولايات المتحده
الكلام ده ما كانش جديد قوي رسل ميد
البروفيسور راسل ميت في كتاب العنايه
الالهيه اللي انا اشرت لحضراتكم اليه في
حلقه بعنوان كيف يمكن ان يحكم ترامب
الولايات المتحده من منزله اتكلم على
السياسات الخارجيه الرئيسيه والتوجهات
الرئيسيه في الخارجيه الامريكيه منذ نشاه
الولايات المتحده وقال ان احد هذه
التوجهات هو انه
الامريكان يؤمنوا انهم لكي يصبحوا دوله
عظمى يجب ان يتبعوا خطى بريطانيه العظمى
بريطانيا العظمى كانت بتعرف انه الدوله
الكبرى لا تصبح دوله كبرى الا باقتصاد قوي
والاقتصاد القوي لا يتحقق الا من خلال
شركات بدي اعمل داخل الولايات المتحده
وخارج الولايات المتحده وعلى الدوله
الفيدراليه وجيشها ان يحمي مصالح هذه
الشركات يعني الدوله بتخدم على الشركات
اللي هي عصب الاقتصاد الامريكي وعلشان
مصالح الشركات الامريكيه
على امريكا امرين الامر الاول انها تسعى
لتهيئه نظام او خلق نظام دولي في النهايه
تعمل في هذه الشركات بحريه ومحابي لها
الامر الثاني ان تقطع الطريق على اي دوله
يمكن ان تهدد مصالح الولايات المتحده
الاقتصاديه اللي هي انشطه شركتها ماذا لو
ظهرت دوله يمكن ان تهدد مصالح الشركات
الامريكيه على الامريكان ان يتحالفوا مع
اصدقائهم لاحتواء هذه الدوله اما سلما او
باستخدام القوه العسكريه الكلام ده يفكر
حضراتكم بايه يفكر حضراتكم
بالتعبير الشهير اللي جرام اليسون
البروفيسور جرام اليسن اشاعوا في الاوساط
الاكاديميه والسياسيه والدبلوماسيه وهي
مصيده
ومن هو
هذا هو المؤرخ والجنرال الذي ارخ لحرب س
واثينا من حوالي 2400 سنه وقتها ادرك
بعبقريته ان الحرب لم تقم بين القوى
المهيمنه واثينا القوه والوليده بالضروره
لان اثينا اضرت بمصالح سبارتا ولكن لان
سبورت شعرت بالقلق من تنامي قوه اثينا
وبالتالي يمكن ان تؤثر على مصالحها
ونفوذها في المستقبل
مصيده
تحولت الى نظريه سياسيه على يد جرام
اليسون المفكر والمؤرخ الامريكي الشهير له
خلاصه نظريته ان الدول او القوى المهيمنه
تصطدم بالقوى الوليده ليس لان هذه القوى
الوليده او القوى الناشئه تضر بالضروره
بمصالحها او بتستهدف مصالحها ولكن لانها
يمكن ان تستهدف مصالحها في المستقبل ودي
نظريه تحدثنا عنها كثيرا قبل ذلك الخلاصه
ان الولايات المتحده تحارب ليست لان
وجودها في خطر ولكن لان مصالحها يمكن ان
تتعرض لخطر لمجرد ان هناك دوله تمتلك من
الاسباب القوه ما قد يمثل تحديا على
الولايات المتحده وده واضح جدا في حاله
روسيا الان وفي حاله الصين واضح بشكل اكثر
طب لماذا يحارب الروس الروس بيحاربه
لاسباب مختلفه تماما
الروس بلد
شاسع ضخم ما عندوش قليل السكان احنا
بنتكلم على حوالي 140 مليون هو اكبر بلد
من حيث عدد السكان اكبر بلد من حيث
المساحه في العالم عدد سكانه حوالي 140
مليون نسمه فقط لا غير وليس لديه موانع
طبيعيه كثيره يمكن ان تحميه تاريخيا من اي
غزو الجغرافيا اللعينه دي بتطارد الروس
منذ قرون طويله منذ زمن بعيد والروس
مهووسون بفكره الامن عندهم دائما هاجس انه
يمكن غزوهم بسهوله بسبب عدم وجود موانع
طبيعيه يمكن ان تحميهم موانع طبيعيه زي
ايه عشان تفهم وجهه نظر الروس قارنهم
بالامريكان الامريكان بلد محظوظ بجغرافيته
هو اولا تحيط من الغرب المحيط
الهادي ومن الشرق المحيط الاطلنطي من
الشمال كندا ومن الجنوب المكسيك يعني ما
عندوش اي اعداء يمكن ان يمثلوا خطرا
وجوديا عليه وزي ما في البعض بيصف
الامريكان بيقول هي امبراطوريه محظوظه جدا
ليس ليها من جيرانها قوه مفترسه جيرانهم
المكسيك والكنديين والاسماك ليس اكثر انما
روسيا بلد لديه 14 جار من بين هؤلاء
الجيران هتجد بلد مثل الصين هتجد كوريا
الشماليه هتجد من الغرب قوى غربيه متحالفه
مع الولايات المتحده وحلف شمال الاطلسي
وبالتالي الروس دائما لديهم شعور بالخطر
الشعور بالخطر ده متوهم يعني مجرد كده
بارانويا ابدا على مدار 500 سنه الروس كان
دائما بيتم غزوهم من الغرب كل دوله بتجد
لديها فائده قوه
بتتجه الى غزو روسيا الذي اصبح لاحقا
الاتحاد السوفيتي على سبيل المثال هتجد
انه البولنديين
سعوا الى غزو روسيا في سنه 1605 بعدهم ب
100 سنه تقريبا السويديين سعوا الى غزو
روسيا بعدهم بحوالي 100 سنه وتحديدا في
1812 قام نابوليون بونابرت
يعني مغامراته الشهيره بغزو روسيا ايضا
بعدهم بحوالي 100 سنه وتحديدا في 1914 قام
الالمان بغزو روسيا في الحرب العالميه
الاولى ثم بعدها باقل من 27 سنه قاموا
بمحاوله ثانيه لما هتلر غزا الروس في سنه
فهم ليسوا واهمين وعندهم خلل جغرافي واضح
القصه دي واضحه في اذهان الزعماء الروس
منذ زمن بعيد الزمن البعيد ده امتى من اول
ايفان الرهيب اللي هو اول قيصر لروسيا اول
قيصر كان هو من سمي بايفان الرهيب ايفان
الرهيب ده ابتكر عقيده عسكريه عقيده
الهجوم من اجل الدفاع لازم اهاجم الشعوب
والقبائل التي حولي حتى اؤمن نفسي من هذه
القبائل هو كان غزواته ثم غزوات بيتر ذا
جرايد ثم الامبراطوره كثرا ثم استلم وحتى
بوتين اليوم كلهم بيقوموا بعمليات عسكريه
بيبحثوا عنها امرين
الامر الاولاني الامن من خلال انه يكون في
منطقه عازله بينه وبين اعدائه
بيبحث عن موانع الطبيعيه والامر الثاني
طبعا انه بيبحث عن موانئ على المياه
الدفيئه وحبذا لو كانت هذه الموانئ موانئ
امنه روسيا امبراطوريه عجيبه غريبه زي ما
قلت لحضراتكم كل الامبراطوريات اللي قدرت
تتوسع وتبقى امبراطوريات عظيمه جدا كانت
امبراطوريات عندها اطلاله ضخمه جدا على
المياه زي اليابان زي فرنسا طبعا زي
بريطانيا زي الولايات المتحده وعندهم
موانع الطبيعيه افضل بكثير من الوضع
الروسي اللي هو دايما منكشف القصه دي
لاحظها وحللها جورج كنن
اللي كان سفير ودبلوماسي بيعمل في
الولايات في روسيا من سنه 1933
وحتى يعني منتصف الاربعينات
وكتب بعد نهايه الحرب العالميه برقيه
شهيره سميت بلانج التليجرام هو عباره عن
تلغراف من 8000 كلمه للخارجيه الامريكيه
بيقول لهم بعد انتهاء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
بحلل السياسه والعقليه الروسيه وخلاصه
الرساله بيقول انه الروس او السوفيت لا
يمكن ان يتعايشه بشكل سلمي مع الغرب الى
الابد ليه لانهم قوم لا يشعرون بالامان
ولانهم لا يشعرون بالامان فالامان الوحيد
هو ان يشتبكوا في صراع طويل مميت لابد ان
ينتهي بالتدمير الكامل للخصمهم او لخصومهم
ووجهه نظره انما خلق عدم الشعور بالامن هي
الجغرافيا هي بلد
ضخم منكشف
ضخم جدا عدد سكان قليل منكسف وبالتالي هو
دائما معرض للتفتت داخلي والخاطر الخارجي
الامر ده مهد الى تركيبه معينه في السياسه
الروسيه ان يكون في انظمه الانظمه دي
بتكون
ديكتاتوريه مستبده ده وفقا لترجي
ومهوسه بالامن الداخلي والخارجي وطبعا
كتير من الناس ايدوا كلام جورج كنان ورووا
ان ده بيتصق مع تاريخ الروس من اول اذان
الرهيب وحتى بوتن الحالي